[Musica]
se avete già sentito questi suoni
significa che avete già assistito ad un
assalto di scherma questi soldi
provengono dall apparecchio elettrico
questo è stato introdotto per rendere
più semplice la vita agli arbitri
durante gli assalti di scherma come
funziona all apparecchio elettrico
apparecchio elettrico un semplice
circuito elettrico un circuito che fa
capo qui alla punta del fioretto
l'obiettivo del fiorettista e riuscire a
colpire con questa il corpo
dell'avversario e nel caso il filetto il
tronco allora si riesce a colpire il
tronco si accenderà sul segnapunti una
luce verde o una luce rossa nel caso in
cui si colpirà un bersaglio non baido
facendo nella luce bianca quindi diciamo
che è semplice capire che queste luci
per noi schermidori e per me quindi
rappresentano croce e delizia e che
possono portarti dall'esaltazione allo
scoperto strumento che io ho provato
molte volte una di quelle che ricordo
meglio era a san pietroburgo sono con le
mani tra i capelli e guarda da lontano
gli altri atleti tirare ho appena perso
per la seconda volta di fila al primo
turno di eliminazione diretta e manca
davvero poco a questo alle olimpiadi
mentre guardo gli altri atleti filare li
vedo distanti che vedo più forti più in
gamba e anche più belle di me e nel
frattempo in me nasce un po una paura
perché mi sento come non pronto per
questa avventura per cui ha dato tanto
questo sogno per questo criticato tanto
o un team di persone fantastiche in cui
ripongo tutta la mia fiducia una fiducia
che però purtroppo io adesso non ripongo
più in me ma facciamo un passo indietro
la mia tenera inizia molto giovane
inizio a 7 anni in una piccola palestra
garage perché mi faceva sentire molto
rocky balboa da ragazzino cominciò più
che per conoscere la scherma ma per la
voglia di stare con mio fratello che
aveva iniziato questo sport un po prima
di me
devo dire però che mi dimostro subito
molto talentuoso riesco a vincere un
buon numero di gare nel tempo però
purtroppo la mia palestra si smuova
rifletti sti è uno sport che fa del
confronto il punto cardine allenamento
questo è un grossissimo
e allora necessità virtù in quel momento
lì di grossa difficoltà la palestra
aveva comprato un manichino per
reclamizzare la tuta sociale
a quel punto l'idea spoglio il manichino
della tuta sociale lo vesto con la
divisa da scherma e iniziò a tirare con
lui si chiamava billi il mio amico e
tirato con lui veramente migliaia di
assalti però ovviamente billi e poteva
portare fino a un certo punto a quel
certo punto arriva a 18 anni quando
arrivò a un bivio o decidere di
trasferirmi in un'altra città frascati
oppure di essere qui
dicevo abbandonare la mia passione
praticarla un po a tempo perso però
ovviamente abbandonando il mio sogno era
una scelta molto molto difficile perché
avrei dovuto abbandonare la mia famiglia
i miei amici
il mio maestro la mia scuola però il mio
sogno era grande la voglia di
perseguirla era davvero tanta e deciso
di fare questa scelta mi trasferì a
frascati inizia quindi una nuova vita ma
nonostante tutto nonostante tutti quei
sacrifici fatti nonostante il talento
nonostante tutta quella passione arrivò
quel giorno lì a san pietroburgo ha così
poco alle olimpiadi al momento decisivo
della mia carriera e perdo per la
seconda volta di fila al primo turno
mi chiedo ma posso sbagliato cosa non ho
fatto cose non ho eseguito in maniera
corretta
ho preso tutto ciò che la tecnologia
applicata allo sport dessero fermi o il
miglior maestro del mondo un bravissimo
lavoratore atletico e in questo mi viene
invece in aiuto la mia psicologa e mi
ricorda come il fattore umano e la parte
più importante di ogni vittoria è il suo
intervento lo posso diciamo prendere
emblematico con questa frase qui una
frase una situazione di nice quanto
manca alla vetta
tu sali e non pensarci questa frase mi
ricorda che in ogni secondo bisogna
gustarsi la propria scalata e io che
avevo un sogno
questa signora mai era diventato per me
un incubo non mi gustavo più la gioia di
vivere il percorso avevo solamente paura
perché la voglia di vincere aveva
prevalso sulla gioia di continuare una
strada e così facendo mi rendo conto
pian piano lavorando sul fattore umano
che il mio zaino era prima di tutto ciò
che con cura
avevo costruito in tutti questi
passa il tempo ma comunque si avvicina
all olimpiade
io desideravo ovviamente vincere questa
olimpiade un oro che mancava nella mia
specialità da vent'anni e questo aiuta
animo s'alternano passo dall'esaltazione
alla tristezza senza mariale ragione
perché con la testa stavo già arrivo ci
stavo già da anni e per me quella
giornata il 7 agosto arriva una giornata
di sole ma ventosa e comincia in questo
modo qui questa foto l'ho mandato al mio
migliore amico dopo aver vomitato due
volte prima dell'inizio della gara e
questa foto vi viene in mente tutte le
volte che mi è stato detto certo daniele
si vedeva proprio che quel giorno ti
sentivi invincibile direi però inserisco
e non ho certezza di dove finirà la mia
gara di dove finirà la mia giornata però
una cosa la so però tutto questo non
sarà nella giornata dei rimpianti nella
giornata del rammarico se qualcuno mi
batterà sarà perché avrà dato qualcosa
in più di me io darò tutto quello che ho
e così la mia giornata inizia un passo
dopo passo stoccato po stoccata assalto
dopo assalto ripetendo quella frase che
mi è stata detta
quanto manca alla vetta tu sali e non
pensarci la rivedo durante tutta la
giornata
e così pian piano scalo la mia vetta e
arrivo in cima superando ostacoli che
fino a quel momento credevo
insormontabili
e su quel podio sul gradino più alto
sarà un daniele uguale a quello di
sempre
eppure in parte nuovo ma guardate come
aspetta il momento giusto per tirarla
garozzo vale d'esultare bene
finita ecc
a conferire la stoccata daniele garozzo
e campione olimpico cosa ricordo di
quella giornata
questo credo sia il momento più bello
non solo di quella giornata linea forse
di tutta la mia vita
un percorso condiviso con mio fratello
in quell'abbraccio c'è tutto questo c'è
una strada fatta di sacrifici la voglia
di arrivare ad esserci riusciti la gioia
che la sua addirittura era più grande
della mia salute le persone che siamo
diventate lungo questo lungo percorso
della medaglia cosa posso dirvi
ovviamente per me è qualcosa di
importantissimo ho sacrificato tanto
viaggiato tanto dovuto lasciare la casa
mia per questa medaglia però posso dirvi
anche che questa medaglia è solo un
valore aggiunto parlato successo ma dato
notorietà ha coronato un percorso mio è
un percorso di squadra e quindi so che
questa medaglia è tanto ma non è tutto
so anche che io farei la stessa persona
che vedete qui oggi anche senza di lei
diciamo che in questi giorni
questo tempo vado molto spesso con la
mente a quel giorno li cerco di
ricordare i dettagli le parole le
emozioni che ho provato perché so che
sarà difficile provare emozioni di nuovo
così grandi però d'altra parte so anche
che indipendentemente in qualsiasi campo
in cui mi cimenterò in qualsiasi
occasione in qualsiasi evento io mi
sperimenterò anche in altri campi
diversi dalla scherma io metterò sempre
lo stesso impegno la stessa passione e
lo stesso entusiasmo la stessa
abnegazione
perché questa medaglia per me
rappresenta solo una retta è arrivato lì
ce ne sono tante altre che ho voglia di
scalare ho voglia di continuare a
raggiungere e alla mia medaglia devo
questa consapevolezza che sarà appunto
la determinazione per cui sarà il motore
di ogni mio percorso e concludo con le
parole di ieri de vito che dice quando
realizzi tuoi sogni non è tanto
importante ciò che ottieni
ma la persona che diventi nel tentativo
di realizzarli
grazie mille
[Musica]
[Applauso]